it was just another normal day for Abu
Omar he was on his way to pray in a
local mosque in Milan Italy everything
around him seemed exactly like it always
had he had been living in Milan for over
two years and I walked down the same
high Wall Streets dozens of times except
today he wouldn't make it to the end of
the streets you see the Italian police
and CIA have been telling him for months
watching his every move leading up to
America's invasion of Iraq Abu Omar was
suspected of radicalizing men to join
the fight against the West in the Middle
East and for the CIA this meant just one
thing he was a Target his kidnapping was
planned for weeks a massive team of CIA
officers had been watching him waiting
for the chance and the day had finally
come as Abu Omar walked down that quiet
streets in seconds A man jumped out
identifying himself as a police officer
asking for Abu Omar's identification
almost immediately after that another
group of men appeared behind him in an
instant they grabbed him shoved him in a
white van and sped off in the van they
drugged him and next thing you know he
wakes up to the sound of prayer and
Egyptian Arabic being spoken Abu Omar
was successfully kidnapped and sent to
Egypt
the CIA team had kidnapped him back to
his home country where over the next
four years he was tortured with some of
the most horrific methods imaginable
without ever being charged with a crime
but he maintained his innocence right to
the end and eventually got released as a
Broken Man and the CIA officers who
kidnapped him well they made some stupid
mistakes like using unencrypted cell
phones and booking into hotels together
an Italian judge even indebted 26 CIA
agents involved but the extradition
request for those agents never went
through Abu Omar's case wasn't unusual
since the start of the war on terror
hundreds of people have been kidnapped
by the CIA and dropped off in other
countries to be interrogated as part of
their extraordinary rendition program
you see under American law there are
very strict laws against torture on
American soil CAA officers can't be
pulling off people's fingernails they
can't hang them by their feet for hours
on end and they can't inject them with
drugs to make them talk but in other
countries like those in the Middle East
these practices happen every day so when
the CAA really wants to break someone
they'll shoot them off to their friends
abroad who will get the job done for
them that that way America keeps his
hands clean and maintains its image as
the human rights upholder of the world
in other words extraordinary rendition
is a neat loophole that allows the ca to
Outsource their torturing much like how
companies Outsource their manufacturing
to China
now as a new CIA recruits there's a lot
you can learn from the mistakes of the
Abu Omar operation if you're gonna make
it into one of the most secretive
morally great CIA teams in the world
you're gonna have to master their
methods so welcome to the beginner's
guide to extraordinary rendition also
known as kidnapping CIA Edition
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the CIA value skill above all to love
your skills are more important than your
educational background your references
or your cover letter and life is the
same thing the right skills can lend you
any job or business in the world not the
degree you have and that's where
skillshare comes in skillshare is an
online learning community that focuses
on helping people all over the world
ReDiscover their curiosity passion and
love for learning they have classes on
everything which means there really is
something for everyone on skillshare
whether you're looking at enhancing an
existing skill learning something
completely new or completely changing
the course of your life plus there
aren't any annoying ads or interruptions
so you can focus on just learning and
when new premium classes being added all
the time you'll never get bored and
you'll have access to topics like this
class on graphic design Basics core
principles for visual design is taught
by Ellen Lupton and has over 141 000
students or this class on real
productivity how to build habits that
last it has 68 000 students and is
taught by author and entrepreneur Thomas
Frank and if you're interested in a new
career pathway why not check out intro
to user experience fundamentals of
usability is taught by Marik McCloskey
and has over 25 000 students from this
class you can learn a skill that earns a
base pay of around 115 000 a year so if
you want to up your skill level and do
what you love sign up for skillshare
right now by pausing the video and
clicking the link below the first 1000
of my subscribers to do that will also
get a one month free trial of skillshare
so you can start exploring what
skillshare has to offer right now pause
the video and click the link below to
join now thanks to skillshare for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
as an extraordinary rendition team your
first lesson is to learn how to spot a
targets they'll tell you targets for
these operations must always be high
value worth the risk of getting caughts
but that's nowhere near the truth you
see dozens of old CIA targets eventually
turn out to be Innocents you just have
to have a reasonable belief that the
person you're going after could be
valuable to the CIA once you do that you
pretty much have the go-ahead while
there is a known terrorist's second
cousin or it's just some guy that you
think might know something that could
help you nail the real targets it
doesn't matter the pool of people we can
kidnap is pretty much infinance because
we can always find a legal reason for
kidnapping him later
foreign
[Music]
targets it's time to justify your
actions you need to make everyone
believe you're gonna kidnap this guy
because you absolutely have to that if
you don't kidnap him right now more
Innocents are gonna die do you want the
blood of the Innocence on your hands
then let us kidnap this guy tell your
higher ups he has obvious links to
terrorism say he has Vital Information
concerning National Security explain
that by capturing and forcibly
extraditing him you'll be taking a known
threat off the streets as long as your
justification boils down to it being
important for National Security you are
good and if anyone asks why we need to
kidnap him and move him into a different
country we'll just say that there's a
better chance to extract information if
the target is interrogated in his native
language and by people who are
culturally informed it's worth to
justify CAA kidnappings hundreds of
times before and it's bound to work
again this time
foreign
[Music]
permission to make him disappear it's
time for the actual kidnapping and yes
there's the guy for that too step number
one surveillance and planning this is
where you get a team together and track
every single second of your Target's
life this may take days weeks or months
if he leaves his apartment at 8 24 am
every day to buy a pack of cigarettes at
the corner store while you follow him
and watch if he uses a public bath from
Nila Park you follow and watch every
move this guy makes has to be carefully
observed and recorded remember to switch
team members around so he doesn't notice
the same people following him around
once you've established his routine when
he does what and why it's time to pick
the moment when he's the weakest the
most exposed that is when you will
strike step number two the kidnapping
unlike the CIA team in Italy your main
objective is to get your men off the
streets and disappear as quickly as
possible without leaving a single trace
of evidence behind people cannot know
this was a CIA up use burner phones to
communicate and always be aware of your
surroundings you don't want to be held
up by the cops made kidnapping then
choose a day that is as normal as any
other follow your target to the most
vulnerable spot in his daily routine and
from there you grab him
some of the best places to do this
include fake roadblocks and quiet
streets at an isolated ATM where he's
drawing cash make it quick use
chloroform if you can and make sure
there are no Witnesses once you get him
in the getaway car you are halfway there
your next step is to get him out of the
country
3 x film here's where America's super
power status comes in handy according to
a 2001 secret NATO agreement America and
its allies have blanket overflight
clearances or flights associated with
operations against terrorism this makes
it easy to head straight to a nearby
airstrip drag your prisoner onto our
private jets and take off within minutes
of the kidnapping by the time someone
notices your guys missing he'll be long
gone on the plane the prisoner is
stripped shaved photographed and kept
Shackled blindfolded and wearing ear
muffs now that you have your target
secured set your destination for the
nearest CIA black site
[Music]
you're not being falsome in your replies
you force me to tell you something I
don't know
now that you have your prisoner in
custody it's time to give the CIA
interrogators the first shot at breaking
him who cares if he has no idea why he
was kidnapped or even if he's the wrong
person if he was approved as a Target he
needs to be questioned and that is where
CIA black sites come in Black sites used
to be a myth something only mentioned in
movies or books but the truth is after
the start of the war in Afghanistan in
2002 the CIA created secret prisons
where they could hold or interrogate
possible terrorists these sites were
located all over the Middle East and the
rest of the world and became known as
dark presence and eventually black sites
one of the most famous was Abu grab an
Iraqi prison where members of the US
Army and CIA committed hundreds of human
rights violations against their
prisoners over the years presidents have
tried regulating that meth is used in
CIA in his interrogation some of the
approved methods include waterboarding
leaving prisoners in extremely confined
spaces forced nudity and sleep
deprivation but in a country as far away
as Iraq these rules are rarely followed
instead the same interrogation methods
the U.S prosecuted countries like Japan
for are committed by Americans on
hundreds of detainees including women
many of them were later released without
charge so you take your prisoner to a
black site it could be a foreign country
or even on Prison ships in international
waters you get interrogators to give
them everything they've got hoping to
break them and extract Intel and if
their methods don't work or the
constrained by pesky human rights laws
or International criticism well then you
can resort to plan B letting other
countries do the dirty work for you
foreign
this is where you drug your prisoner
again shove him onto a plane and send
him off to a country with little to no
care for human rights and no human
rights Watchdogs countries like Syria
and Egypt are top picks Here Local
soldiers and police officers are well
versed in committing crimes against
humanity here your prisoner would be
subject to some of the worst torture
methods imaginable stuff I definitely
can't mention on YouTube that can keep
him in a Cell for years at a time
without being charged they can do pretty
much whatever they want in the name of
extracting information and if your
target ever becomes obsolete they're
just as happy to get rid of him too all
this happens while U.S foreign policy
strictly States no assistance may be
provided under this part to the
government of any country which engages
in a consistent pattern of gross
violations of internationally recognized
human rights and if people start asking
too many questions well then it's time
for the cover-up
foreign
to every U.S president ever America only
uses enhanced interrogation techniques
set up by the Bush Administration and
when it comes to handing prisoners over
to governments who don't care as much
well we can't control what other
countries are doing sure somewhere some
CAA or government officer knows exactly
how many fingernails these other
governments have pulled off how many
times prisoners have been beaten or just
how long it takes to break and accuse
terrorists into a sobbing wreck but you
know out of sight out of mind even
though the UN prohibits sending people
to countries were there substantial
grounds to assume they'll be tortured
America has always maintained that it
just can't be sure what Memphis these
other countries use and the biggest
cover-up excuse of all everything is
totally legal as long as these countries
promise they're not going to torture the
people delivered to them and when those
promises are broken well what can you
expect from such a lawless country it's
not our fault they don't follow the
rules
this video has definitely been on the
edge of what is monetizable on YouTube
that is why I started making private
documentaries that you can only watch by
clicking the join button below that way
I can make even more touchy videos like
the next one coming out on every Jeff
steam or our previous ones on Monsanto
and MK Ultra these are things they will
never teach you in business school for a
tiny tiny tiny fraction of the price and
if you join and you don't think it's
worth it email me and I would personally
refund you the money so yeah click that
join button below and if you're new here
subscribe for the best documentaries on
money power and crime that's it stay
dangerous out there and I will see you
guys in the next one
[Music]
thank you
[Music]